California Governor Jerry Brown recently
signed a law that bans paparazzi from
flying drones over private property yeah
they can't do that yeah all I have to
say is it is about time now as someone
who has chosen and I accept that to live
in the public eye I can tell you these
paparazzi drones have been getting more
and more invasive it takes a toll on me
and it takes a toll on the people around
me who have never ever hate don't get me
wrong I don't hate the paparazzi if you
sky see me on the street on a public
beach snap away fine I get it for a
5-minute planet location get out of here
yeah
[Applause]
how did she get that so fast it's around
the front page John John don't waste
your time with Conan hey Johnny Depp is
filling in the next door next door to
the next studio so come on over here
drone come here I'll show you come here
John come here
[Applause]
it's still alive and II get it some more
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]